it's Friday Eve
who's looking forward to the weekend uh
me yeah yes Amy laughed nervously at the
top of the show she and TJ who are both
married to other people were not wearing
their wedding rings we're told both TJ
and Amy had split from their spouses
before news of their relationship became
public it's tough to have two playbooks
you have to have one Playbook The
Fallout Amy's ex Melrose play Star
Andrew Shu has scrubbed his wife from
his Instagram removing all photos of her
both Amy and TJ deactivated their
accounts and then there's this
ET has confirmed that Amy and Andrew are
close to a deal to unload the New York
City Apartment they once shared the
three-bedroom two-bath home is under
contract to sell for 5.2 million dollars
a source tells ET there has still been
no word from management addressing their
relationship but that's all anyone can
talk about around the office of course
now the past is coming back to haunt
them there are no secrets for a happy
marriage if you do the right thing you
treat each other well you respect each
other back in 2012 TJ was asked how he
and wife Marilee phoebec make it work I
think you start with marrying someone
who was considerate and kind and good
which he is so that helps because you
have a good foundation to start with the
GMA Scandal reminded us of another
Morning Show couple Joe Scarborough and
Mika Brzezinski no you can't yes I can
the morning Joe anchors were married to
other people when their show began so
you had the feelings and you were trying
to push them away and then that's
correct well tell us about it that
pretty much says it I um I totally
understand that I'm being completely
difficult but that's about as far as I'm
going to go what about the Saturday
Night Live skit oh my God oh my God yeah
I'm a stinker and it's not gonna work we
were like ah no doubt SNL will address
the news this weekend
[Music]